toby is fantastic to see you here at
collector mania Milton Keynes have you
been having a good day I've got a man
day it's my first convention so it's as
I was just saying the early comic-con
I've seen his on Entourage with Johnny
chase for Viking quest so it's slightly
different and there's loads of people
dressed up
I should have go in my dress and my
sword now of course it must be fantastic
being part of this massive show of
course you announced at Comic Con last
year tell me a little bit about filming
for example that scene in the water
gardens where Bronn knocks you out yeah
well I spent most that day on the floor
really I thought it's gonna be a really
big well I didn't actually I was reading
it when I read it when I read this ain't
the first time neither was my big scenes
are gonna be this man and kind of show
him turning from a boy into a man but
obviously he gets completely wiped out
by brawn but it was good fun I just laid
in the Sun frying in my dress like for
hours and hours on end and it didn't end
but it was great and the water gardens
are amazing you have to do very little
because well first of all were the first
people ever to film in the water gardens
in the alcázar palace
no one's ever had the permission to film
before I think it was hard for Game of
Thrones to actually get get permission
but they got it and we were there for a
few weeks
so you get there and obviously most sets
even if they're outside they've always
dressed up and stuff but the water
gardens were kind of untouched and as
you can see from shots they are
absolutely
stunning and breathtaking so that said
that sets a tone on its own you know you
bring your own work to it but that
really sets the feel straightaway you
mentioned there about him being a boy
turning into a man but then in getting
knocked on his backside
my friends laughed for hours
they sent me lots and lots of videos of
them more watching the TV in their flats
well my different friends with all their
flatmates and they will watch me going
oh my god he's gonna do it he's gonna
knock out bow and they burst in
hysterics I'm like thank you one of
those gift worthy moments isn't it yeah
it is yeah of course it's that moment
where you get to have your revenge as it
were on bran don't you but your father
Doron says that you know you need to be
a good ruler and you have to make a
choice about what you're gonna do I mean
what do you think about his choice yeah
just start making decisions
yeah well bully it is true I mean it we
went back hundreds of years ago or even
now that's how you would get your you
know the younger ones are your kids if
you were of royalty that's how you're
getting so make the decisions or not
even a royalty even in business or
something you'd get them to make these
smaller decisions even though they're
very big in the grand schemes to most
people but I think that you know and he
sets bran free but that's because he's
not a killer and bit like Duran who
would have had to have killed at times
because he is a ruler it's not really a
killer you know he's a very he's very
diplomatic he's very wise and his wisdom
is kind of what carries him through and
what would have got him to where he is
now not violence and not you know
not kind of just jumping out and just
acting the war so I think that trystane
will probably follow in his father's
footsteps
in terms of his wisdom but he's a lover
as well I guess he is yeah so what do
you think about actually mentioned
during there do you think that his
interactions with Jamie are genuine and
that he doesn't want anything happening
or do you think that there might be
something bubbling in the background he
might have some kind of greater scheme
that he's got in mind
you know what I wish I knew I I think
that I think that I think he's just
threatened by Jamie I think that he will
see he'll be with his his lover or his
girlfriend and it's the best-case
scenario an arranged marriage could ever
be I mean how many times we ever heard
of that never it's always normally you
know not very nice and not as easy as
this they just get on house on fire but
then you've got Jamie who comes in and
he knows exactly who he is and he walks
in and he will know him as the
Kingslayer you know no Stella would have
talked about him but he will have had
its own theories about who Jamie was
before Marcello ever came to Dorne and
he's from King's Landing so even though
most seller marrying Tristan or the idea
of them getting married you know the
idea that one day they'll get him
married to form this alliance even
though that's all set in place it
doesn't mean that people from King's
Landing are all going to be completely
welcomed they're just not so he looks at
Jamie as a threat because he's got this
girl that he loves but suddenly this
bloody guy comes into the mix who
actually has known Marcella way longer
than he has it makes sense to me it's
how you would be you know you would be
like hey come in T how do you think
Tristan will get on in King's Landing
because Doran said that he's going to go
send him to King's Landing he wants them
to own a small council doesn't he like
over him was everyone keeps telling me
this I hope I make it I mean I hope
everyone's right
I really do I I pray that everyone's
right but who knows it's Game of Thrones
I think I could get killed by poisons
caterpillar in the woods I could be like
I could die from the least manly death
in all of Game of Thrones history had to
go how would you like to go
I'd like a big death a big kind of
dragged out sad death little dribbling
from everyone wailing over you now of
course you've also had your cousins
before the show this season the sand
snakes what have you made of them well
they're fierce
fiercely tough and very scary and rather
good-looking too and they're all
gorgeous I mean in person they're all
they're not they're feisty they're
feisty girls but that's they're just
really cool confident feisty girls in
real life but their characters are yeah
they're pretty scary I think that I
don't know too much about it I know of
some stuff from the books and I know
obviously Webb we're veering off from
the books now but Tristan is very very
different to his three cousins they're
all warriors and he could be a warrior
you know he could ride so that but we
haven't really seen it we haven't seen
that's not what he's known us but I
think they're great I just loved the
scene that we've just seen with
Rosabelle but all three of them
obviously in in jail behind bars but
Rosabelle in Jerome bran was just such a
great scene she's fantastic
really really great have you thought
about the reaction that fans have had to
dawn this season because obviously this
is a new place we've gone in the show
well I I've heard mixed things about
people with you know people's reactions
to dawn but the harnessing is we've
never seen dawn before so it's
I think it's a weird one because there's
there's two things I've got asked a
question earlier and that was what do I
think about the outrage or people's
feelings of outrage towards the sunset
start seeing after marriage to that I
said well there will always be a scene
where someone's horrified you know like
it's Game of Thrones it's HBO if we were
talking it was on Fox or ABC or
something we wouldn't have those scenes
we might have a hint of them but we
wouldn't have them that's why it's good
HBO the only network one of the only
networks owned cables that could
actually do it and show but something
like dawn I mean we've never seen it
before we've heard of it the only things
we've really heard well the only little
mentioned some Dornish wine and Dornish
silk and then we obviously had open but
you know in my eyes I would have thought
reason why Oberyn was so you know he was
so kind of passionate and cool the way
that he walked around and he held
himself in a certain way that was all
for a reason because that was the
promotion for what we're gonna see in
dawn so I'd like to think that more
people think Dorne is new and refreshing
and interesting and colorful and you
know and and quirky but I think there
will be a lot of people to find it hard
because there are things there are
changes or I don't know if they're
changes but there are things that
haven't been mentioned like in the books
I have an older brother or an older
sister and they haven't been mentioned I
don't know what's happening I can't say
but I know a lot of people find that
hard when I first of all cars people
were like what the hell him well Ariane
what about Quentin you know it's not
good there is so much that they can't
fit everything onto a page so I think
that the I think that everyone here
today that I've met have loved till the
dawn stuff because they've just found it
since they just some people come to me
and just said the color of dawn and just
the outfits
I don't know how they feel regarding
with the rest of the story because the
problem is you spend five years and they
they want to see their favorite
characters they want to see Tyrion they
want to see Jon Snow and Daenerys you
don't I mean they want to see and Cersei
because that's who they've invested in
but the beautiful thing about Thrones as
it kills off your favorite characters
but whilst whilst they're building up
your favorite characters they've got
about five five or ten simmering in the
background and then when the big ones
come by that time comes these ones in
the background of suddenly our new
favorites you know they they constantly
kill and replace so in a very rubbish
answer I don't know how likely are we to
see you in season six and what would you
like to see happen for trystane if you
do make it back well I don't know
anything and that is the truth like Jon
Snow you know nothing I know nothing I
know nothing just a motto but we're out
of my way I would I'd go to King's
Landing and I would fight my way to the
throne with nothing but a spoon
some good I'm not sure how far you get
with just a spoon you should see me once
I get I have a spoon if you fighting
someone over dessert maybe ten years of
spoon training yep no armor needed
what's the likelihood we'll see you in
the finale of the show and what can we
look forward to in the finale well I
don't know about me but I know that from
what I've heard it's gonna be pretty
gruesome as always and pretty
jaw-dropping and I'm the same as
everyone else that's walking around here
everyone comes up to me and says that
they can't wait in there pitching to
watch it and I'm exactly the same I
think when I think when people can't see
you and you're in the show they think
that you're not itching to see it - and
they think that you know everything but
I know nothing does though I know
nothing I really I don't know I don't
know anything
most of someone I know what I'm doing no
I am after time so V is that you yeah I
know know who so be talking to you Toby
I'm glad you had a good day at your
first Comic Con and we look forward to
seeing you at lots more you too thanks
very much
you